Now we are almost there.
What I would like you to do now is think about
when you analyze an algorithm using pen and paper,
how would you go about that?
What you basically say is every program here and your variables here,
so how do you get from here to here?
So basically, it's a number of rules that look like this.
If we are at a certain line of the code,
so say we are here, and usually that line of code will
also use some variables, but it doesn't have to,
but usually it will of course,
so certain variables are set to a given value.
Then we know what the program is going to do next.
For example, it's going to jump to the next line of code,
and it's going to modify this variable here.
So how many of these rules are there?
Well, for a single line of code,
it depends on the variables here,
and let's assume that one line of code uses a maximum of 3 variables.
If you were to count how many of the rules there are,
it's the number of different values that one variable can take
times the number of different values that the second variable can take
times the number of values that the third variable can take.
So for one line of code,
that's actually just O of 1 as the constant.
Why is that?
Well, because we set that on the RAM variables can not get arbitrarily large,
so there's only a constant number
of different values that a variable can take,
so even if we have 3 different variables
and consider all of the combinations,
it will be a huge number usually,
but it will be a constant number
for one line of code.
Now if we're not looking at one line of code
but all lines of code,
then this actually doesn't change,
because we have a constant number of possibilities for each line in the code
and the program has constant size just as before.
So there's a constant number of rules
that will tell us exactly what the machine is going to do
in the deterministic case.
We're going to go to the non deterministic case in a minute,
because there of course, as we just found out, the if-then rules don't work.